[Music]
what
hello and welcome to I'd like to know
our question and answer program well we
get the privilege of answering your
questions from the word of God my name
is CA Murray I'm I am in the company of
Pastor Steven bore Pastor as always good
to have you here a great privilege to be
with you and Pastor David Salazar Pastor
again good to have you here thank you
Pastor for allowing me to be with you
today yeah you will notice that we smile
a lot on this program and that's because
we like the program we like studying the
word of God this is something we would
do even if we weren't paid to do so we
we just like studying the word of God
and and we tease each other because we
study independently but when we come
together our minds are almost always in
Harmony and I think that is because of
the Holy Spirit who superintends all
that we do here we seek to serve the
Lord we seek to do his will we seek to
answer questions from his word and so
when you start out with that premise God
will lead us to the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth which is
what we promise to do for you when you
send in your questions to give you the
truth as we understand it from the word
of God it's a little late in Earth's
history to Banter about the will and the
way of man we want a word from the Lord
and that's what we promise to give you
if you will write your questions to TV
ATS tv.org that again is TV
atoms as in Mary tv.org o RG we will get
to your questions just as soon as we
possibly can you will forgive us if it
takes us a little while to get to those
questions because we have many of them
they are coming in from around the world
which pleases us because it lets us know
that our reach is going worldwide but it
may be a little frustrating for you
because you don't get your questions one
or two weeks after you send them in but
we promise you we will get to them we
make you that promise and so Pastor
Salazar if you would pray for us we'll
start out with our first question for
today absolutely let's pray gracious
heavenly father as we come before you
this moment to ask your leading and your
guidance of the Holy Spirit as we speak
from your word help us to pronounce
things that are right according to your
will may we answer questions that will
give guidance and light to those that
are hearing and watching and we pray
that again you will be in the midst of
us we pray in jesus' name amen amen and
amen all right our first question comes
to us from illan Madu and I wish he had
put down where he is writing us from but
he did not but ilan's question is I am
having a problem recognizing
identifying what my spirit what my
talents are hence how do I work for God
all right any questions any answer
answers rather for this particular
question you know Pastor C usually a lot
of young people have this question often
I find and I don't know if if your
friend ilham is uh you know young or or
or older but usually young people have
this question where what are my talents
how do I know what exactly I can do for
the Lord and so I would like to for I
believe one of the ways we can start to
answer his question from the word of God
is is the verse that we find in 1
Timothy chapter
4:2 and it's a verse that Paul of course
speaks to a young person and you know in
this verse it says let no man despise
thy youth but be thou an example of the
Believers in word in conversation in
charity in spirit in faith in Purity and
I will say that one way even if you
don't know exactly just yet what your
talent is maybe you don't know if you
have the gift of preaching or of
Prophecy or what not there is a command
of the Lord to start with be an example
in and it speaks of you know being
example in word in conversation in
charity in love of course in spirit in
faith and in Purity so to start you know
before we start asking Lord how or what
talent do I have I believe that you know
I am person or anybody should really
first ask God to help him be an example
in service in showing love in showing
the right word in in acting and behaving
in a way that honors the Lord
I believe that as we do that as we
become an example in these areas God can
open up your your the gifts that you
have be best stowed by him and you will
be able to either realize or recognize
what talents are maybe in the same
experience you will realize you have a
talent to speak or you have this talent
to uh be a leader or perhaps one that
can teach young people so I believe that
the main thing the the the beginning of
that process of discovering your talents
comes from submitting yourself to God
and finding that call to be an example
in in the small things in your life you
know in your in your Purity in your
behavior in how you speak thank you very
much
Pastor I think that uh uh this
individual
Ilan uh really can ask two questions of
himself
number one what are you good
at and number two what do you have a
passion
for however not
always what we're good at or not good at
and what we have a passion for is what
God has called us to do many times it is
but not always I can give you a personal
example when I graduated from uh High
School from Wisconsin Academy I was 18
years
old I went down to Venezuela where my
dad was a conference president I was
going to spend the summer there I
graduated in May of 68 was going to go
down until September go back to Andrews
and get a physical education degree so I
wanted to teach pe oh wow I was good at
ping pong I was good at softball I was
uh pretty good at um you know athletic
activities because that I thought
thought that was my gift but then
something happened I was invited to
speak at the church in nagua which is
the town where the university
is and I
thought why would they invite
me I had never spoken in
public people don't believe me I was an
introvert I was afraid of my own
shadow and so why would you in invite me
to preach at the church 18 years
old kind of like a
nerd and uh I said why do you invite me
well you're a pastor's son and if you're
a pastor's son the pastor's son has to
know how to
preach and
so it was crazy but I accept it and so I
wrote out all my sermon word for word
and on Sabbath I preached or I read
[Laughter]
and after I finished my sermon because I
told my testimony I had three members
come up and say you should not be a
physical education teacher you should be
a
pastor and you know afterwards that was
working my mind why would three people
tell me that I should be a pastor after
after reading my
sermon it was a I thought it was a very
mediocre sermon but many
times other people can see gifts in you
that you can't see take Jesus what did
he see in Peter what did he see in John
what did see he see in Simon the Zealot
yeah my counsel
is ask Discerning people in the
congregation what they see in you that
you might not be able to see in yourself
and you'd be surprised at how God will
reveal to you all that you can be amen
because others see in you what you don't
see in yourself and so sometimes overtly
we have gifts that are discerned but we
many times have gifts that are not
discerned to yourself because uh we have
a tendency not to see ourselves as we
are but others can see us as we are amen
so that would be one counsel that I
think would be valuable uh for Ilan MH
amen I want to coign part of what you
said because uh when I was growing up
our church was fairly large about 800
members and I was asked to be the youth
leader of that church oh in my early
teens and um people would say to me you
ought to be a pastor you should be a
it's and and sometimes you you should
take that seriously when people see a
gift in you that you don't necessarily
see in yourself listen to what they say
particularly older people who have some
experience with the Lord who have walked
with the Lord a while you know some
people come to you put their hand pastor
and they they they call you Pastor Sito
you know you little Pastor kind of thing
um but listen to the counsel because
Others May see gifts in you um I also
put down things that you like and things
that you have a passion
for um Ellen White says that we ought to
do those kinds of things that glorify
God and that uh lift up his kingdom I
want to read something very quickly and
it's not this one it is this one while
it is in the order of God that chosen
workers of Consecration and talent
should be stationed in important centers
of population to lead out in public
efforts it is also his purpose that is
God's purpose that the church members
living in these cities should use their
god-given talents in working for Souls
so find something that you can do to
work for Souls one of the things that
working for Souls does is it it opens up
your mind to other talents that you make
may have and you will find that in
blessing others you also are blessed um
if you can take a mission trip those
kinds of things many young people and I
use the term find themselves by doing
things for other individuals and they
they find things that they like things
that God has given them ability to do um
there is a text that I'm going to
stretch the the meaning of uh Isaiah
30:2 21 which talks about you're going
to hear a voice saying this is the way
walking in it um I think that also can
apply to when we want to do things for
the Lord to ask the lord lord what am I
good at what do you want me to do and He
will lead you I think through
discernment through the counsel of other
individuals through things that come
natural to you to apply those things to
the work of God to the glory of God and
you can you can uh uh find out a little
bit more about what the Lord wants you
to do take your time and make it a
matter of prayer illan because God wants
you to be comfortable but he also wants
you I think to stretch yourself you know
uh move into some areas that you may not
be totally comfortable in uh when I was
growing up uh and going to college we
had to do call portering you know you to
get your degree you had to spend a
vacation sometime in call now I am not a
good Callo I just you know that's not my
I'll Stand in the pulpit and beg for
Souls out but going door too is not my
strength I remember once I had a book to
sell and there was this this guy had
this attack cat this this vicious cat
this is a cat and I'm standing at the
foot of theair say you know I'm letting
this cat stop me from knocking on this
door but this cat was vicious and you
know back hair up and kind of thing and
so I said Lord get this cat out of here
and um so I just walked up the steps and
I stomped on the step and a cat took off
I said well praise the Lord knocked on
the door I got a sale but I'm not I've
never been good at call portering that
really stretches me um but we had to do
it so you got to do it so you want to
try some things that maybe are not
natural to you uh and see if God is
giving you a leaning or a talent in that
particular area and you will find that
God has given you some Talent sometimes
that we are aware of many times we are
not aware of until we exercise the faith
to move out in that area that's right
now one of the reasons why U pastors are
generally not good at curing is because
what we give we give for
free I like that praise praise the Lord
praise the Lord and then then then too I
was you know someone told me a story you
know I don't have any money I just I
really want that book but you know it's
hard I given a book then you got to pay
for that book you know so you end up
losing money out of kindness so try
those things and you will find that God
will bless as you uh do those kinds of
things thank you Ilan so much for that
particular
question um the next one comes to us
from Lorinda Thorp do I have that
correct Lorinda Thorp she is writing
from British Columbia in Canada I had a
cousin uh my first cousin uh played for
the BC Lions football team many many
years ago uh uh Bute we used to call him
he played for that for that football
team my question is about the common
saying God will never give you more than
you can handle as I hear this often said
in church circles due to our difficult
sinful nature towards self-sufficiency
to manage things on our own rather than
allowing his power to replace our
weakness does this notion not reinforce
our
independence are we not given
circumstances that test and shape our
character through the crucibles of life
in order that we may recognize our
inadequateness and turn to the Savior
for support and deliverance beyond what
we can handle I I love this question
because she kind of answers her question
in in her in in her qu answer she kind
of deals with her own question but um
who wants to take a stab at this pastor
bour Pastor Salazar I mean I could start
and I think that probably one of the
reasons why we say that or is said
commonly among uh Christians the idea
that God will never give you more that
you can handle is based on the verse
found in 1 Corinthians chapter 10 verse
13 where it says there had no temptation
taken you but such as is common to men
but God is faithful who will not suffer
you to be tempted above that ye are able
but will with the Temptation also make a
way to escape that ye may be able to
Bear it so the
the phrase God will not give you more
than you can handle I believe it's
somewhat based on this verse on this
text now uh I think the concern that our
friend has here is in regards to does it
make us self-reliance on ourselves and
forget that we have to rely only on the
Lord and I think that the answer in the
verse in the word of God is not you know
for you to rely on yourself to trust
your own ability or or your own you know
power to come out every Temptation the
only way out of it is if you are
submitted to the Lord if you are able to
connect with God there is a actually a
warning right before that verse verse 12
it says wherefore let him that thinketh
he standeth taketh heed lest he in other
words if you feel comfortable in
yourself I know it enough uh God will
you know has given me ability to be able
to overcome things on my own you will
fall but if you rely on the Lord and
this is why part of the concept of
falling are not not falling into
temptation is part of the prayer that we
are to do to the Lord like let me you
know let us don't lead us into
temptation but Deliver Us from Evil
that's the experience that we have to
experience we have to rely on God always
always every single time and yes God
will open a door so that we don't fall
into temptation but it's never really
the the Bible never speaks of us relying
on ourselves and it's always about us
trusting and relying on our communion
with God and him giving us the victory
or the ability to overcome any
Temptation well said there's a tendency
these days even within our own
church to
justify sin
because we have a sinful
nature in other words the sinful nature
is weak therefore we can't overcome
sin however what these people are saying
is that our sinful nature is so strong
that even the power of God cannot
overcome it all right it's really
limiting the power of God it's not
saying that our sinful nature is weak
what it's saying is that God isn't
strong and um it's true that God allows
us to go through trials because as we go
through trials we become stronger it's
never God's intention that we become
weaker that we give up that we throw in
the towel it's always God's intention
when he allows us to go through trials
and temptations to make us stronger in
resisting temptation there's this text
that we find in the Book of James 1 and
verse 12 which says blessed is the man
who endures temptation
yes or it could be translated trial as
well for when he has been
approved he will receive the Crown of
Life which the Lord has promised to
those who love him and then of course
how could we forget that beautiful text
in Hebrews chapter 4 in verses
14-6 seeing then that we have a great
high priest yes who has passed through
the heavens Jesus the son of God let us
hold fast our confession in other words
let's remain faithful to the Lord amen
why can we remain faithful to the Lord
for that means because for we do not
have a high priest who cannot sympathize
with our our weaknesses but was in all
points tempted yes not as Adam was
tempted as we are yet without sin and
then comes the secret let us therefore
come boldly to the throne of grace that
we may May obtain mercy and find Grace
to help in time of need of course the
time of need is when tribulation and
trial and problems come to our lives uh
you know the process of character uh
development is compared in the Bible to
going through the fire right yes you
know Psalm 12:6 says that silver is
purified seven times uh you know the
three young men that were thrown into
into the fiery furnace that was literal
fire yeah right do you think that they
came out of the fire stronger than they
were before they were thrown into the
fire of course how about Daniel do you
think his faith was even stronger after
he came out of the Lion's Den than
before he went in of course because when
God intervenes in our trials and
sometimes he
delays and God comes through we say Hey
you know I went through this trial and
God gave me the victory so when the next
trial comes which is stronger MH we
overcome again yes and so you know we
all know that text that says I can do
most things through Christ who
strengthens me right some some people
read it that way you know I I can do
most things through Christ who
strengthens me or I can do all things
except overcome sin through Christ who
streng strengthens me that's not the way
it is not you know there is power to
overcome and there's never an excuse
excuse for sin amen amen amen amen nice
little commercial for last generation
theology well done and you know Pastor
just to I wanted to just sort of give
this thought also in second in First
Peter chapter 5 verse 7 it speaks of of
you know says casting all your care upon
him for he carth for you so when we are
going through these trials and we or we
Face
uncertainties part of our experience is
to
put that and live it to the Lord what we
cannot handle and yet right the verse
after that the Apostle Peter commands us
or or reminds us that we are to be sober
diligent Vig Vigilant because your
adversary the devil as a roaring lion
walth about seeking whom he may devour
so first he tells us cast your cares
upon Him put all your cares upon the
Lord but remember that you have to be
diligent you have to do your part you
have have to uh seek God and be willing
to understand that there's going to be a
conflict coming and when you are with
that experience of casting your your all
your worries or your curses into the
Lord you will be able to resist the the
devil who comes as a lion and the
victory for the Temptation for the trial
is not our own victory has never it
never is but is that experience of us
trusting God that he will at the moment
at the right moment even if he delays as
Pastor B was mentioning you know the
experiences even if the is delayed he
will come through and give us the
Victory and rescue us if we have to be
rescued you know through the experience
I have to read First Peter chapter 4 12
and 13 go
ahead uh here Peter wrote beloved do not
think it strange concerning the fiery
trial interesting fiery
trial which is to try you as though some
strange thing happened to
you why should it be strange notice the
next verse but Rejoice yes when have we
gone through a trial where we
Rejoice but Rejoice to the extent that
you partake of Christ's sufferings amen
that when his glory is revealed you may
also be glad with exceeding Joy
absolutely so be joyful in Trials here
MH you're preparing for the Greater Joy
where there will be no trials in the
Kingdom Come amen you know we are never
tried more than Jesus was tried true but
when we go through trials we experience
at least in miniature the experience
that Jesus experienced and we share so
to speak in his sufferings amen I want
to add very quickly because time is
going to get away from us Hebrews 13:5
and 6 after paraphrase we can boldly say
God is our helper amen so we're not by
ourselves his promise never to leave us
nor forsake us in John chapter 6 um
picking with verse 5 and I'm looking at
my clock then Jesus lifted up his eyes
this is the Feast of Passover so
Jerusalem was never more crowded than
that Passover time he's looking at this
large group of
people the Bible says in verse 5 uh he
lifted up his eyes and seeing this great
multitude of people coming towards him
Jesus he said to Phillip where shall we
buy bread that these people may eat now
this is Jesus talking to
Phillip Philip's like are you kidding
you're the Lord we lean on you asking me
were we going to get bread so uh the
next verse helps us it says uh but this
he said to test him for he himself knew
what he would do so so the Lord does put
us in situations to test them and just
because we are clueless does not mean
that God is God allows us to come into
these situations and he he and not all
testing situations are from God
sometimes we put ourselves in in bad
situations but this is one where God was
testing Philip's faith and and really
the faith of all the disciples because
nobody had any bread nobody had any food
but he happened to to speak to Philip
and Philip I don't know you know we we
we we got this little kid with five and
two but we don't know what we're going
to do uh so his his faith fails but God
will allow your faith to be tested amen
uh he will put you in situations that
when you get out on the other side you
know it was God and not you just because
you cannot see the other side does not
mean that God does not know the other
side he put you in he will get you
through he will get you out the Bible
says he brought us in so that he could
bring us out not leave us there stranded
uh uh and and alone and I think when
we're in testing times we need to
remember that that our Victory is in
Christ as you well said and not in us
and it comes from from the Lord what of
the persons who had had the greatest
test in the Bible for Abraham m when God
told him to take his son and sacrifice
him yes yeah I mean Abraham had to
decide well uh you know um God says Thou
shalt not kill so that must not be the
voice of God he didn't think that way no
right he knew the voice of God and he
was severely tested but let me ask you
did God come through and when he came
through was the faith of Abraham
strengthened as a result of the trial
that he went through of course because
you can always see after the storm mhm
you can always see God's hand through
the storm and afterwards you can see how
God brought you out of it precisely and
so you know we just need to know that
what God allows and sometimes what God
causes is for our good even though it
might not appear good when we're going
through it yes yes though he slay me yet
will I trust him the thing is to have
implicit trust and surrender to God and
know that all things do work together
for good you know sometimes it looks
very bad when you're in the middle of
the storm as you well said but on the
other side as you look back MH I can see
myself growing I had a good friend who
was an ambassador uh at the UN who I
baptized in Adventist Church he got
fired from his ambassadorship thought it
was the worst day of his life but God
brought him through brought him back
brought him into the church he became
Regional director for MetLife and uh
retired as the director for MetLife from
Boston down to Atlanta uh would have
never had that had he not gotten fired
as ambassador from the island of Grenada
to the United amen so you know all
things were together for good to those
who love the Lord I sure do again we
thank you for being with us today
hopefully we've said or done something
that has helped you and will bless you
on your road to glory we encourage you
to write your questions in we will get
to them and we promise as soon as we can
it is tvom
tv.org our time has fast slipped into
eternity allow me in closing to wish you
both Grace and peace through our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ we'll see you
again soon bye
[Music]
byebye